[Music]  the world  is aware of a threat  above our heads but have no fear  we will do whatever is necessary  witches have always known more than they  should let me find out what  [Music]  the skies are darkening the world's  changing  we need to unite for the great war  not from here are you how did you get  here  [Applause]  he's connected to this place he's got  something to do here  i think we both do  [Music]  if this is the great war then she will  be needed  there is something else something that  will be the difference between winning  and losing  the bearer of the knight will have their  own task  and that could put the person in great  danger  there's something evil here  [Music]  the fate of many worlds may rest on you  [Music]  you